BY TYLER.
>> OF OVER TO
THE SITE IN A SENSGOOD
BOSTON OFF OF THE
FOURTH  TO FILIP
ZADINA , HE
WAIT  TO REPLACE HIS
MAN AND WHAT HE DOES
HE MAMA JOINED
THE RUSH.
THAT WAS A NICE
DROPPED COYLE.
>> Jack: BRUINS.
HE KEEPSFINISHING TOUCH
THAT IS A PRETTY GOOD S
THEY CANNOT MAKE
TRANSITION.
HE SPEEDS INTO OF EYES,
HE WAS STILL OUT
THERE.
HE GETS IN THE OF NOVEM
THE THIRD PERIOD IS
UNDERWAY.
HE AT THE.HE TRIES
THE ROOF ONE OF AND STO
ALEX NEDELJKOVIC .
THE FORWARD, A
>> Andy: IT STOPS IN
THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
HE DID NOT HAVE MUCH
ON IT.
THAT WAS A BIG SOLID
HIT . THAT WAS A ICY RE
BACK TO DAVID
PASTRNAK
NET . DO NOT BE
THE SCORES.
THE PAST TWO PATRICE ON
GONET.
IT OPENED UP A NICE
PASS TWO PATRICE
THE HE
THEN THE BOMB GOES L.
OVER THE NET.
IT WILL DEFLECT.
ONE SHOT ON CENTER
SCOREBOARD.